ultimately this is not about me
this is about you the readers
protecting reporters sources tonight at
8 pm eastern on c-span
the warren commission released its
report on the kennedy assassination 40
years ago in september the assassination
archives and research center hosted a
symposium on the commission's findings
this panel looked at possible
connections to the cia
this is a little over an
hour afternoon
we have with us
jefferson morley who
is
a reporter for the washington post
and
has written a
series of articles over the past two or
three years
which have made stunning revelations
in particular about the
cia's obstruction of the probe by the
house select committee on assassinations
john newman as most of you know is a
former major in army intelligence he's
now a professor
at the university of maryland
uh he's a long time researcher has been
doing
seminal work on the case for for many
years
the two of them are combining as sort of
a tag team this afternoon to give you
a presentations on on what the warren
commission missed
unwitting participants and unindicted
co-conspirators
[Applause]
uh thank you jim is that working
is that uh
thank you jim
uh john and i decided to
team up today
because of our uh mutual interest in
the cia and the kennedy assassination
and in particular in an area that we
have done a lot of work on
uh together and apart uh on uh what cia
personnel uh and officials knew about
lee harvey oswald before the
assassination
uh so we're going to run through that
today um just by way of introduction
uh or setting the scene for what we're
talking about um i think that this
conference is helpful uh useful and
important because it brings together uh
on the 40th anniversary of the warren
commission a snapshot of the continuing
decomposition of the credibility of the
warren commission report
uh we've known long known that the
substantial solid majority of the people
of the american people uh are skeptical
of and reject the warren report's
conclusions
uh
thanks to david talbot we have a more
complete picture now of how the
political elite uh privately shared many
of those uh suspicions lyndon johnson
bobby kennedy fidel castro richard nixon
j edgar hoover
and
for the purposes of our conversation
today the one point i would like to note
is that many of these people despite
their very different ideological
perspectives and
mindsets
came together to arrive at a general uh
conclusion that the assassination had
somehow originated in the world of
cuban-american politics
um
what we are going to uh
look at today is
what cia officials knew about lee harvey
oswald before the assassination and how
they responded and how they handled that
knowledge afterwards
and john's going to pick it up here
the fine work of the assassination
records review board has given us nearly
six million pages of new documents
a lot of the material is new and
includes significant evidence from cia
records
evidence withheld from the warren
commission
while the evidence in these records is
insufficient to determine who the
ultimate
perpetrators of the crime were it is
sufficient to establish that oswald's
cuban escapades were part of the plot
the documents make it clear that many ci
officers became enmeshed in these
escapades
both in new orleans and mexico city
and at headquarters after the
president's murder covering it up we
know of at least a dozen such officers
at the c i a
due to time constraints jeff and i will
identify several of them but only talk
about three
in more detail
we believe two of these cia officers
were unwitting participants and the
third was an unindicted co-conspirator
in the conspiracy to kill jfk
it was their job to know about oswald
and to take action concerning him with
respect to the incoming reports on his
cuban capers before kennedy was killed
while unwitting in the plot their
collective responses played a
significant role in the intelligence
failure that culminated in the
president's murder
in a nutshell a ci officer that jeff
will discuss shortly manipulated oswald
in a manner
to establish the story that oswald was
an agent of castro
while still others at ci headquarters
that i will discuss
took actions that suppressed that story
from the mexico city station
they did this at the very moment oswald
went to mexico city to put his cuban
story in play
in a failed attempt to obtain a visa to
go there to cuba
you may draw me out further on this in
the q a but i'm going to move along
what the station learned about oswald's
cuban contacts in mexico city they
reported the headquarters
those reports
and the taped phone conversations of a
conspirator who impersonated oswald to
further link him to castro and the
kremlin were destroyed and covered up by
cia headquarters after the president's
murder
while these reports and tapes were thus
destroyed the story itself was not
president johnson used it to force earl
warren and others to take part in a
national security cover-up
i will deal with that part shortly
but first let's take a closer look at
some of the ci officers who handled the
oswald cuban student director dre story
before the assassination
for the purposes of this uh
discussion here i'm going to start on
august 1st 1963.
on that day a man named george joe
anitis was promoted to become the chief
of the psychological warfare staff in
the jm wave station of the cia in miami
george joe andes at that time was 40
years old he was a 10-year veteran of
the clandestine service
he reported directly to deputy director
richard helms
five days after oh and and
among the chief among his duties in
miami was handling of the cia contacts
with one of the most prominent and
effective anti-castro exile
organizations the directorio
revolucionario estudantil student
revolutionary directorate also known in
the american press as the cuban student
directorate and sometimes by its
initials dre
in cia files that
joe and edie's generated on the group
the group was known by the code name
amspel
this is joe anita's fitness report you
can see that it was written on july 31st
1963 the day before he took over and you
can see in the bottom line he's the case
officer for a student project involving
and these are important terms political
action propaganda and intelligence
gathering those are important because
five days later lee harvey oswald
wanders into the new orleans chapter of
the dre and announces that he wants to
help them in their fight against castro
this is oswald the alleged leftist
the dre
rebuffs his advance and begins to
engage in intelligence collection on
oswald they send people out to find out
who he is a political action they uh
accost him handing out leaflets on the
corner uh they challenge him to a debate
on the radio they tape the debate on the
radio and then propaganda they put out a
press release denouncing oswald and
calling for a federal investigation of
his activities this is three months
before he has assassinated president
before he allegedly assassinated
president kennedy
at the time joe andes was uh joe nedes
was supplying the group with up to
twenty five thousand dollars a month
that's probably about a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars a month uh in
today's money and
the dre his assets the and spell assets
proceed to
do the intelligence collection keep tabs
on oswald uh and um
uh and make a big deal of his pro castro
uh connections
these incidents draw the attention the
street fight between the dre members and
oswald draws the attention of the fbi uh
and the incident is taken seriously by
federal authorities we don't know joe
and edie's response to that the records
of his activities in august 1963 are
missing from the cia files but we do
know that the report on oswald and the
dre was forwarded to washington now john
will pick up the story here
oh in a second yeah
no
just
turn it off
okay
go ahead okay
we just turn that off
oh no
all right
that fbi report on oswald and the dre
as well as another one earlier on his
fpcc activities
in dallas before he went to new orleans
were sent to ci headquarters in
washington
and the one on oswald in the dre landed
on the desk of jane roman
on october the 4th
jane was a liaison officer working in
james angleton's counterintelligence
staff
the oswald dre story then went to two
officers working at the
counterintelligence section of the
agency's cuban affairs staff the sas
les will put that up now rex
and it stayed there for three important
days
the eighth ninth and tenth of october
during those three days
it was during those three days at cia
headquarters and its mexico city station
exchanged cables on oswald and his
escapades in mexico
you want a fighter
go ahead
i'm talking about right here this is the
eighth ninth and tenth and both of these
individuals work in the counter
intelligence section of the special
affairs staff that's where
the
oswald dre story was sitting in the cia
at the time that the station and
headquarters exchanged information
on oswald
now in the mexico city station that's a
cover sheet by the way you're looking at
a cover sheet to that dre report the the
report that the fbi report that we're
talking about this is the
routing sheet that people sign for when
they read the doc the documents in this
one in particular was that
fbi report
when the mexico city station after
discovering oswald oswald's activities
there asked headquarters who he was
the headquarters response was authored
by john witten um alias john celso
here's his signature right here on the
bottom of the cable that was sent from
headquarters
he was the agency's chief of covert
operations for mexico and central
america
now jane roman participated in the
coordination of the headquarters
response as you can see here's her
signature on both of these documents
here
a response which concealed from the
mexico station oswald's activities with
the dre and the free play for cuba
committee
in as much as it says and this is just
the last paragraph our latest
information is the state department
report dated may 62. well of course it
isn't because they've got all these
reports
that they're reading the very people who
are writing and coordinating on this you
can find there's jane roman there's her
signature up there
so in essence headquarters is
suppressing the story not informing
its mexico city station
of oswald's cuban
activities in new orleans and in dallas
in an interview at which both jeff and i
were present jane admitted she said
quote i know i'm signing off on
something that's not true
her involvement however was minimal and
she told us that whatever operation it
was was very closely held and it was in
the sas which
comports very well with the documents
being right there an essay sas
counterintelligence at the time
both jeff and i found her account
credible when she gave it to us in the
mid 1990s and we still feel she was
telling the truth
it's more difficult to know whether john
whitten the chief of the mexico and
central america desk and the drafter of
the response that concealed the cuban
story was privy to this sas oswald
operation
he had greater responsibility for the
headquarters response than others like
jane who were only in on the
coordination
was he signing off on something he knew
wasn't true
if the fbi reports were withheld from
him
then he might have believed there was
nothing in the file since oswald had
returned to america 18 months earlier
on the other hand he might have like
jane known about the reports
but was told that withholding their
contents from the mexico station was
necessary
to support some ongoing counter
intelligence operation whitten died in
january two thousand before anyone had a
chance to ask him
based on his genuine effort to get at
the truth of the cuban story after the
assassination
jeff and i believe that much of the
story was probably withheld from him at
the time
that he drafted this cable he was
certainly sore
after the assassination about
the information on the cuban story that
helms withheld from him then you can
find that in his hsca
deposition released a couple of years
ago
and i think i'm going to turn it back
over to jeff at this point
this takes us up through this takes us
up through oct uh october 10th 1963
as the
cia headquarters registers the
information that that oswald has been in
mexico city oswald of course returns
to dallas takes a job in the texas
school book depository
he has a gun he's not identified as any
kind of threat to the president
on the november 22nd the motorcade
passes by the school book depository
shots ring out kennedy is killed
90 minutes later oswald is arrested
how jane roman john whitton and george
joe anitis responded to the development
that of oswald's arrest illuminates what
the cia would and would not share with
the warren commission
john witten was working at cia
headquarters that day and he recalled uh
in one of his reports the effect of the
announcement of oswald's name and
whitton said uh the effect was
electrifying
oswald was not an unknown commodity in
the western hemisphere division of the
cia his name meant something to people
and that's why they were electrified
the next day whitten immediately began
to
try and recover all information from cia
files that he could do and the next day
in a meeting in deputy director helms's
office helms acquiesced to witten's wish
to take over the review of all oswald
files this was a plausible request
whitten was a experienced
counter-intelligence investigator he was
one of the leaders in introducing the
polygraph to the cia it was natural that
he would take over such an important
investigation
jane roman two in her description in her
interview with me and john described
going immediately going to work to see
what could be found out about oswald
in miami most tellingly george joe andes
laid low
he received a phone call around five
o'clock from the members of the dre and
one of the the member who made that
phone call has described it in some
detail to me
and the members of the dre called him
and said we know all about this oswald
fellow we ran into him in new orleans
and we're going to publicize everything
we know
joe andes reportedly replied let me
check with headquarters i'll get back to
you
the dre didn't wait for his response
they immediately went public but there's
no indication and this is from the
former members of the dre four of them
uh joe and eddie's never got back to
them to tell them not to go public or
not to do what they did
um they immediately started calling
reporters and by six o'clock the story
of oswald's uh uh activities on behalf
of the fair play for cuba committee in
new orleans were being broadcast around
the world uh the next day the story was
featured prominently in new york times
washington post washington star miami
herald miami news and countless other
stories and so in this way the amspell
program that joe andes was running came
to shape the initial perception and
media coverage of the opera of the
kennedy assassination and in light of
joe and edie's responsibilities for
psychological warfare this is especially
revealing
um joe and edie's uh
was
stayed in close touch with the group uh
in the days after the assassination he
helped extricate one leading member
uh from uh from cuba
he did not act like a man who was
surprised that his own agents had been
in touch with a presidential assassin he
acted like a man who was running a
covert operation
and now john's going to pick up with
what happens uh in the days that
followed
when president kennedy was murdered
there was a huge problem
as insiders like joe needs whitman and
roman and others immediately recognized
oswald looked like an agent of castro
and the kremlin and the ci had known
about it for six weeks before the
assassination
and again i've talked about this and
give given presentations on this i'm not
going to show you a lot of documents
about that
today
furthermore oswald's activities with the
soviet and cuban embassies in mexico
were in the cia's records as a result of
the fact that a conspirator had
impersonated oswald on the telephone in
the mexican capital on saturday morning
just 20 hours after the murder lbj and
hoover talked about this very sensitive
problem
but within 48 hours the tapes of that
impersonation were made to disappear
at that time or soon after the cables
from the mexico city ci station were
altered to delete all references to
oswald's cuban contacts there
in this way
the story of oswald as castro kremlin
agent a story that the cia itself had
helped to create
was eviscerated from the cia's
pre-assassination records again we can
discuss this further in the q a
but you might also want to contact ben
wecht who
was the sort of the organizer of that
great conference last year and you can
get all the documents that that i put
together for the presentation there to
lay out the evidence for the covering up
of
or actually the alteration of those
cables and for the suppression of the
tape story
but the story itself
that castro and or the kremlin might
have been behind the president's
assassin
was now used to force a national
security cover-up
and we'll put the next one on there rex
hoover and deputy attorney general
kotzenbach worked out the details on
sunday afternoon and on monday morning
katsuba completed the story in
coordination with lbj's top aide bill
moyers
this is the famous kotzenbach memo and
essentially it boils down to this it has
to show that oswald did it no
conspirators were at large it was not a
communist conspiracy and furthermore it
was not a right-wing conspiracy dressed
up to look like a communist one those
were the ground rules and the warren
commission never wavered from these
ground rules these parameters
president johnson then used the secret
story of oswald and his castro kremlin
ties as leverage to form the executive
commission to head off any congressional
investigation of the president's murder
let's go to the next one
you may have seen some of these at other
parts of this conference for my purposes
i'll just remind you that this is
the leverage being applied to senator
russell who did not want the job was
forced into the job
with the argument that 40 million
americans were going to die because of
who oswald was
uh and let's go to the next one rex
oh it's not the one you played yeah you
listened to this
during rex's oh okay
well i'm my purpose is only in
establishing that he's using this world
war three threat to to
pressure uh people into taking the job
and including the chief justice himself
earl warren
who refused the job was asked twice by
by bobby kennedy order down to the white
house refuses johnson and as as he says
i just pulled out that little story on
mexico city that hoover told me and he
had him in tears he had him crying
um
now unless you uh this is of course the
uh the the lbj tapes
but if you don't believe lbj um let's
take a look at the next one earl warren
himself confirmed this story on weta
public television right here in
washington years later
where he told the same story except for
he left out the part about crying but
essentially that that johnson said
there's a threat of nuclear war and
given that
he said i'll have to take the job
this ensured that there would be no real
investigation
the raison d'etre for the formation of
the commission itself was averting a
nuclear war
the commission was not told what the cia
knew about oswald before the
assassination and from its inception the
commission had to comply with the
kotzenbach parameters
oswald acted alone there was no
communist conspiracy and no right wing
conspiracy that is the legacy of the
warren commission that it never examined
the true story of oswald and the cia
which is where i feel the smoking gun
really lies
and i was invited to make a comparison
uh with the 911 commission and i'll do
that
right now and
very briefly
i think this legacy has been repeated
not just in the 911 commission but in
the joint inquiry as well as 9 11
commission in as much
as the smoking gun
was never examined
and i say that because two weeks after 9
11 the fbi announced that they had found
the smoking gun
in the 911 attacks but two weeks later
they buried the story completely and you
can ask me more about that at the q a if
you're you're interested but
i see some parallels there
jeff
uh
since 1963 we've learned a lot about uh
what this what the warren commission
didn't know
and particularly with the work of the
review board in the last uh since 1994
we've come to a much clearer picture of
cia pre-assassination knowledge of
oswald um we've also learned a lot about
what insiders like jane roman john
whitton and george joe and edis did and
their response is
not in the immediate aftermath of the
assassination but in the years and
decades afterwards also illuminates uh
what the
the heart of what the warren commission
missed
um
jane roman
was a very loyal
cia employee her husband was a career
officer who was very close to alan
dulles she never spoke about the these
matters to anybody until john and i
interviewed her and when when we
interviewed her we found her to be quite
candid
it was apparent to us that she had not
carefully considered what the oswald
paper trail showed and when we showed
her the oswald paper trail she described
very candidly what it showed to her and
that was that somebody in the agency's
special affairs staff the anti-castro
operation had a keen interest in oswald
and that was reflected in the handling
of the october 10 1963 cable
uh she said it was these people who had
uh who had
and she did not know who they were
and i believe that she did not know who
they were
had arranged for the the dissemination
of the inaccurate information to mexico
city about oswald
she expressed no qualms about this and
she endorsed the warren commission's
findings in our conversation with her
john whitton on the other hand uh
thought that oswald's cuba related
activities had to be investigated after
a couple of weeks
after helms had named him to run the
internal file review on oswald was
nearing completion of his uh preliminary
report uh when he was allowed to look at
the fbi's preliminary report on oswald
as well and he realized upon reading
that
that report at the at the white house uh
in early december that uh richard helms
and james angleton had not been sharing
all of the cia's information about
oswald with him
whitten felt deceived he immediately
returned to caa headquarters and
complained to helms and angleton about
this and he related all this in sworn
testimony to the hsca which was not
declassified until 1995.
helms relieved him of his investigatory
duties on the spot uh and he returned to
his uh other uh uh other activities in
in the western hemisphere um he only
told he he uh finished his career at the
cia and lived out the rest of his life
in self-imposed exile in vienna austria
he only told the story once to the hsca
um
he did not talk about conspiracy in that
uh in that deposition but he did
emphasize that he did not think oswald's
background had been properly
investigated and that the question of
his cuba related activities was one that
he was especially interested if the
investigation had followed his course he
said that he would have gone into miami
and tried to determine what people knew
about oswald's activities there
uh he was never allowed to do that i
would guess that the reason that he was
never allowed to do that is because that
would have led him straight into the
arms of george joe and edis the man who
had been running
the cuban group that had the most
contact with oswald and was busy
disseminating the story that uh oswald
had acted at castro's behest
george joe and edis thought the story
of what he had been doing had to be
hidden and he did his best for the rest
of his life to make sure that it
remained hidden
um his role in funding oswald's
antagonists in the dre was hidden from
the warren commission david slauson
confirmed that in a conversation with me
recently
the dre's conspiracy mongering the
linking the public linking of oswald to
castro uh was not the subject uh was not
a subject that joe and eddie submitted
any reports on
um
and he went uh in april 1964 he was
reassigned and went on to other
assignments in saigon and athens
15 years passed and in 1978 when the
house select committee on assassinations
reopened the jfk probe and the
investigators from the hsca began to go
to the cia asking hard questions and
demanding files
the cia called joe andes out of
retirement and put him in charge as the
agency's liaison with the congressional
investigation
joe anitis never disclosed his own role
in the events of nineteen sixty three
uh i when i figured out uh and obtained
the documents uh and the interviews that
described and documented what joe andes
have been doing and presented them to
bob blakey
he was quite astounded he remembered joe
and edie's well
and so did other investigators on the
hsca and he said that
he had law his previous endorsement of
cia cooperation which he had signed as
part of the hsca report saying that the
congressional investigators had received
with the cooperation of the cia he said
he would now retract that uh that this
was a violation of trust that
it was his understanding that nobody
dealing with the uh with the with the
investigators would would have been
operational in 1963 uh blakey went so
far as to describe joe anita's actions
as uh obstruction of congress uh and a
felony
and blakey tells me that he feels that
the revelation of joe and edie's roles
in 1963 and 1978 makes him more inclined
to see the cia's hand in a conspiracy
and less inclined to see the mafia
um
joe and edie's uh lived in retirement in
potomac until 1991 when he died he was
never questioned about his knowledge of
the events of 1963.
so
looking back over these uh over these
people
and the history of what they knew
where do we come down i think john has
made clear
jane roman clearly had pre-assassination
knowledge of lee harvey oswald's
activities she received reports on him
she signed off but she was in uh she was
in no way winning uh and
she would be an uh
an unwitting participant
john whitton is a little more deeply
involved because he had authority to
sign off on those cables about oswald in
october 1963 so if there were inaccurate
statements putting out he bears some
responsibility unfortunately uh all the
documentary evidence uh that's around
this was never able to pro uh able to be
presented to uh john witten
i was looking for him in the late 1990s
uh and had tracked him to austria but by
that time he had moved to a nursing home
in pottstown pennsylvania where he died
so we were never able to question him
george joe and edie's is a different
story um
he never reported his contact between
his agents and a presidential and
accused presidential assassin and every
cia officer who who i've talked to
regards that as
either highly improper or highly
implausible uh uh
every cia officer i talked to said that
joe nedes was under a firm uh
legal professional obligation to report
the contacts between the dre and oswald
as their case officer um
several of them several cia officers
said that due to the sensitivity of the
material he might have done so orally
and not on paper i do believe that may
be true but if so we have no record and
there is no record anywhere of what joe
andes reported
the fact that he returns to the jfk
story 15 years later and is in a
position to thwart congressional
investigators asking about these matters
i think has to be taken as an indication
of bad faith he was more than an
unwitting participant i don't think that
there's any there is no evidence that he
had advanced knowledge of a plot uh so
he certainly could not be uh called or
suggested in any way that he was a
co-conspirator but he does seem to have
been an accessory after the fact to hide
what the cia knew about oswald before
the assassination
in legal terms i think
i would describe him as an unindicted
co-conspirator and with that we'll close
and take questions
[Applause]
because we need somebody up here with a
microphone to sort of
hand it up to
thank you uh i have been going over a
lot of the same ground recently and i
want to concur and expand on some of
what you said
first with a general point
whitten was a stand-up guy he was one of
the few cia witnesses
among any before any of the bodies who
really wanted to provide some real
information
one of the things i felt i learned from
his testimony
which is very connected what you're
saying is that inside the cia
nobody knows anything about what anybody
else is doing
it's set up that way that's the way it's
supposed to run
now getting specific
and this was explained by another
helpful witness for the most part sam
halpern
who was the deputy of desmond fitzgerald
who was the head of sas and who
explained that sas had been set up in
1963 or late 62 as the get castro branch
that was its job and it was fully
independent from the rest of western
hemisphere
and actually jeff the one thing i would
question what you said although you may
know more than i do is joining
reporting directly to helms i would have
thought he would report directly to
fitzgerald but i that's only supposition
on my part
now thus it makes perfect sense
that if sas
knew something about oswald which other
people didn't which i think they did
they would have
wanted that fbi report in their custody
and it makes perfect sense that they
would have allowed this cable traffic
that originated in mexico city and went
back to be handled by somebody else
in wh-4 when they knew the truth now the
other point i want to make has to do
with the warren commission
skelso as you point out was originally
appointed head of the investigation and
head liaison to the warren commission to
respond to inquiries
what
no no skelso skelsa
skelso is written yes wait okay
that was wrong in the sense that if you
really wanted the liaison to be
the person who would know the relevant
information about attempts to kill
castro etc it would have been somebody
from sas it would have been fitzgerald
or a deputy of his so they've already
pushed it one level away from the people
who know anything
but what i found fascinating was even
that wasn't good enough and it had to be
moved
yet further away to angleton who had
absolutely nothing to do with it
so
uh i really applaud what you're doing
but i think this is a very important
thing to understand about the cia and
it's totally different from the fbi
where information is constantly freely
shared
the cia is set up to do the opposite and
lastly yes most important point of all
halperin was being questioned about the
amlash case
and and somebody from the church
committee had seen the mlash file and
there was a note on the amlash file
that this file wasn't supposed to go out
of the branch that is out of sas without
the permission of the case officer
and halperin explained that that was
more or less normal procedure and in
fact
that if you sent
if you asked sas
has lee rv oswald work for you he didn't
use that name this is what he was saying
and if the case officer for lee harvey
oswald
didn't want anybody outside sas to know
then they would not find out i mean it's
as simple as that i mean well you
wouldn't ask did he work for you you
asked for information about lee harvey
oswald but that specific piece of
information would not be provided a
helper was very clear if if you didn't
want to provide it right
thank you david um i'd just like to make
three comments uh in response to that
first of all yes the information was
very tightly held i think the importance
of jane roman's testimony to john and i
was that uh the information was being
held in sas and it was it was the
intentionality that she was talking
about that that somebody was taking
action with regard to oswald's file
fully knowing
that he was an object of their interest
we don't know who those people were but
i believe jane that they were in special
affairs step who george joe anders
reported to is a very good question um
he was supposed to submit monthly
reports on the dre all the case officers
in miami did this we have the we have
the reports on the dre from september
1960 up to november 1962.
joe and edis takes over the handling of
the dre in december 1962 and that's when
the paper trail on the that's when the
the monthly reports on the amspell
operations stop
there are no monthly reports on on the
dre for the next 17 months until april
1964 when joe andes is reassigned to
athens and then the monthly reports on
the amspel program start again
so uh what happened to
was joe and edie's
reporting in writing those records have
never surfaced
there may not be monthly reports but
there are a tremendous number of reports
on specific things yes but but the case
officer synthesis of what's going on
with the group there are there's a
17-month gap and it coincides exactly
with joe anitti's handling of the group
and the third point on sam halpern uh i
think i think his testimony on this
point is well taken and the points well
taken there but i interviewed sam
halpern twice uh on the uh on the with
the tape recorder going and asked him
who ran the dre in miami on behalf of
the cia in 1963 and he
told me in two separate interviews that
he had no idea after i uncovered joe and
edie's personnel file and
demonstrated that he was handling the
group he sent word through his friends
in the chat groups that he knew all
about george jo and eddie's george joe
anitis was a stand-up guy and wouldn't
have had anything to do with the kennedy
assassination so
we can see that there's a level of
unwillingness of cia insiders to come
clean about what joe andes was doing in
1963 and we still don't we still don't
fully know
sure
um
john
john newman said to ask in the q and a
about the found the smoking gun
the 911 smoking gun
yeah okay no not the 911
well
when when i wrote oswald in the cia at
the time
um
we could see that these uh
there was something terribly wrong with
a lot of the the reports the the
inaccuracies and i remember talking to
jeff about at the time and didn't have a
framework for for putting it together so
we just called it smoke one smoke two
smoke three smoke four in the chapter
the smoking file
but years laters i had time to reflect
on it and went back to the archives and
looked at more of the records less
redacted it occurred to me what we were
looking at were two parts of the problem
there was one part to create the story
the other part was to suppress it
until 11 22 because if you didn't
suppress it oswald isn't going to be in
the window up there with a gun
it's it's he's a very threatening
profile if you think about it two-time
defecting kami pinko
uh
ex-marine who threatened to give uh
classified information to to the
russians in front of the
um soviet uh us consul and the soviet
union
um and then he's down there in mexico
city meeting with uh kgb assassin
valerie kostikov and all this sort of
stuff so if
if if the story is told if the dre story
is revealed to the station it it
escalates his profile which was already
bad enough but there were a number of
other things that i pointed out in the
book at the time
the the turning off of the of the uh
alert status on oswald the fbi the very
day the mexico story city hit
uh the the failure to provide the mexico
city station with the photographs of
oswald they asked for and there's i
could go on there's about 10 things and
when i looked at them collectively they
all looked like suppression of a story
keeping a virus dormant if you will
until such until 11 22 at which time it
played out
in in its role uh and helped
head off any uh true investigation i
mean how do you murder the president of
the united states and ensure that the
cia and the fbi aren't going to
investigate it you needed a world war
three story or something like that to
function like that so
that's why i felt uh in in the out years
that that the the real smoking gun was
the pre-assassination
not just this cooking up of the story
but controlling it suppressing it and it
took fire firemen in various places some
in the cia and some of the fbi to do it
and that's my operating concept right
now i might be wrong but that's the way
it's beginning to look to me
and i think i might pass on 911 for
sake of time unless you really want me
to go into that
you do yeah
all right well i've been working on it
for about the past five months i have
about seven chapters written so i'll try
and do it in in one minute
um
the the fbi you know
al qaeda didn't didn't acknowledge uh
that they did this thing right away so
we thought that they did and so the big
the name of the game for the first
couple of weeks was to find out the
evidence
and it turned out to be evidence of
money transfers from the united arab
emirates
and in particular one individual
and so when they discovered these wire
transfers the fbi announced to newsweek
and and other organizations ah we found
the smoking gun linking bin laden to to
this to this case well two weeks later
they found out who this individual was
uh he was a british agent omar saeed
omar ahmed
saeed sheikh
who had kidnapped americans kidnapped
british caused deaths and who had never
been brought to justice because we
didn't indict him and we didn't put him
in prison neither the british because
he was our penetration of the senior al
qaeda leadership
had trained the uh the pilots how to
live in the west
um in in pakistan
and working all the time with the head
of pakistani intelligence
and the the two of the three uh key core
commanders in pakistan were his bosses
uh the the fbi found this out two weeks
later when they examined omar cell phone
records
and
in the show you know showed the the uh
the conversations with uh with the isi
chief that's the the head of pakistani
intelligence and how the last hundred
thousand dollars was actually
uh
obtained and given to atar here and that
was that they kidnapped a an indian uh
shoe sales tycoon
uh ransomed about 830
or so thousand dollars from him sent a
hundred thousand of it to omar and uae
and that last hundred thousand dollars
are transferred on august 14th here with
which they used to buy the airline
tickets to fly their recon missions and
their final flights but it couldn't have
come at a worse time the revelation of
those phone records occurred on the 8th
of october the very day that
british and american forces were going
in
to afghanistan and it was about the
worst thing you could discover that a
british agent had been a lot of let off
the hook for his crimes by the americans
and the british because we thought he
was our window in fact our only window
into the senior al-qaeda leadership
uh was a very damaging story for for
musharraf who we needed as an ally for
tony blair
and for the the bush administration
and that was the who the nine the
smoking gun really turned out to be and
that story was suppressed and i don't
wanna it takes a lot of time to tell you
how it was and and what the media
coverage was but within three weeks it
was gone
and by the way he is the person who who
murdered uh
wall street journal reporter
daniel pearl a few months later
getting back to kennedy yes
i want to commend jeff and john for the
great work they've done uh and i think
it's you know moved uh all of our
understanding forward and i think
they're to be commended and jeff i hope
you get your book contract to uh to put
this all
in book form i'm curious uh
it seems from what you've said that you
can have a benign kind of analysis of
what was happening with the dre and joe
andes and oswald up until november 22nd
i mean oswald was a strange character
ex-soviet defector you know surely
our intelligence is going to be
monitoring him but i'm very curious what
happens immediately after the
assassination as you point out with news
stories with various disinformation
pieces being circulated then immediately
after the assassination
uh about uh oswald and his connection to
the communist world and i wonder you i
don't think you mentioned david phillips
but obviously he's a key figure he seems
in a lot of people's research
who do you feel was disseminating this
information about oswald immediately
after was it just the dre were they
doing it
under orders from someone in within the
agency and if so
um
uh it's a good it's a it's a good
question um and it's a little bit uh
it's a little bit unclear um
uh
the the members of the dre uh didn't
need any uh prodding to jump on the
story of lee harvey oswald and i think
that was probably by design um there
there are possible benign
interpretations of of what was going on
in august 1963 uh that would render uh
joe and edie's uh either incompetent uh
that he simply missed oswald missed his
significance um failed to report on him
and that he subsequently after that had
to hide that
uh mitigating against that is the fact
that uh in april 1964 george joe and
edie's on his job evaluation in every
category received a 99 or higher rating
the highest possible rating he could
have received so he had the total
confidence of his superiors whatever he
knew uh uh he did he did not fail to do
anything that his superiors wanted to do
in 1963. that's the first point um a
second point uh i mean oswald's
biography became known very quickly the
the importance of the amspel operation
is that they deliver factual
confirmation of a cuban connection not
merely of oswald's general leftist
inclination or his time in the soviet
union but his recent activities in the
recent past on behalf of
a a procaster organization the fair play
for cuba committee
so uh
their their impact is very strong on the
first and the first day's coverage of
the uh of the assassination other people
are also doing that i should say too
that uh the dre's campaign to link
oswald and castro was not limited to
just these phone calls to reporters on
the night of november 22nd
one member of the dre uh called claire
booth loose the wife of henry lewis the
editor of time life magazine probably
the most influential figure in american
journalism claire booth loose told the
story of receiving a call from a dre
member late on the night of the 22nd and
telling her that the dre had hard
evidence
that oswald had been working for a cuban
assassination team in mexico city
well
whatever we make of that story the
remarkable thing about it is that the
caller from the dre knew that oswald had
been in mexico city at that point the
night of november 22nd there were a
handful of cia people and j edgar hoover
were the only and people in the cia
station in mexico were the only people
who knew it how did a 27 year old
engineer head of the dre
how did he know that oswald had been in
mexico city we don't know i think the
figure of david phillips is important in
understanding the larger context and
john's going to talk a little bit about
him
yeah i i actually wrote something in
probe many years ago about this not not
not very much so if and if you have that
or the person who asked the question you
might want to go back and look at that
so right off the top of my head
it's very interesting at the time that
lee harvey oswald was in mexico city
somebody was promoted to to head of uh
covert operations for cube at that time
that was david atlee phillips
in fact he was it was it wasn't just a a
uh it was a promotion uh not just for
the job he was doing but gs15 he had he
forever if you look at his personnel
record he
um he hadn't been promoted forever for
over 10 years i think i'm just
doing this from memory now
but uh
sure enough when oswald went to mexico
city david alley phillips is promoted to
a gs15 which is kind of you know that's
that's the benchmark to get and if
you're a government
service person here you know what i'm
talking about gs15 is would have you
know bottom rung of a club
um
and
even more intriguing than that
is that during that three-day period i
was talking about before when the dre
oswald story crashes into cia
headquarters on those three days 8 9 10
october and these this cable exchange is
going on between headquarters and the
station
he takes this tdy to miami and i think
probably the headquarters too although i
don't know evidence for it but there
there is evidence in the files that
shows
uh the the the plane or the flight
arrangements on eastern airlines i
believe uh to miami and back and going
to jam way
so uh he's coordinating something
with jm way at the very time these
cables are exchanged and i'd make one
other point
his testimony to the hsca is one of the
reasons that we know that those cables
from the station were altered
there are others who also remember
having put in the cables in fact
practically everybody who was in the
mexico city station said so
to the hsca or the review board under
oath
that they did
report oswald's contacts with the cuban
consulate and so on but but phillips
uh told an even better story to the
washington post
uh and this is the missing in my book if
you if you're familiar with the missing
transcript of monday where he talks
about receiving money in exchange for
information
um
so
uh
phillips has is was deeply involved um
in in cuban operations and he and he
ended up taking taking over at the very
time that oswald brings his
fpcc credentials and and the cuban story
into the
into the mexican capital
and and they send all these reports back
and forth to headquarters about it so
he's in the middle of it but you know
and of course this is completely
separate from what gate and fonzie did
and and all the rest of it but uh when i
got in to put the electron microscope on
mexico city you know i found here there
he was right in the middle of the story
one addendum to that is uh
david atley phillips was stationed in
havana in 1960 when the when the
revolutionary student director it was
first formed by anti-castro students on
the university of havana campus uh
phillips recruited the members uh of the
uh of the organization and when they
faced suppression from the castro forces
on campus helped them to uh to migrate
to miami and establish the operation
there so david atlee phillips was in on
the creation of the revolutionary
student director he was its case officer
in the in the uh at the very beginning
he praises the group quite highly in his
uh biography as does howard hunt so the
the the use of the of the dre as an
instrument of u.s policy in the early
1960s i think is very clearly
established and so to david's question
about
you know who's guiding this thing
we don't know exactly but i think that
the fact that that david phillips is the
godfather of the dre within the cia
speaks very strongly to his knowledge
and intentions around the group
yeah brad
you know you're going over
george how do you pronounce his last
name again joe anities joe anities okay
um
you know i studied a little bit about
the student the cuban student
directorate and one of the things that i
found out was um that they seemed to
show up in different places where there
was a conflict between them and some pro
castro elements and i'm not talking
about oswald in new orleans but uh
particularly tampa florida which i did a
thesis on
and um in october of now or excuse me
november and december of 1961 there were
some demonstrations in tampa which had a
lot large pro castro uh community
and which um
there were demonstrations and at the
demonstrations there were anti-castro
cubans particularly the cuban
revolutionary council
and the
dre attended some of these
demonstrations around the same time guy
banister was working out of the same
office in new orleans with the cuban
revolutionary council the same small
building and they were well aware of
each other's presence um the thing is
what i'm trying to find out from you is
now and you you mentioned
jonadines
was um became head of the uh or rather
directed the operation of the dre in
what was it december 62 i think of the
date yes okay because the dre was uh
getting in conflicts like the crc was
with the anti or with the pro castro
cubans in tampa
and i was wondering if you have any
evidence that this was a specific
purpose
yeah i mean
to basically get involved in uh little
scuffles
with pro castro elements in the united
states absolutely it was and you saw on
on joe and eddie's job evaluation he was
supporting the group for political
action intelligence collection and
propaganda and so these confrontations
with pro-castro groups were part of why
the agency was funding them and this
continued throughout in september 1963
just a couple weeks after the dre's
encounters with oswald joannedes gives
four leaders of the dre 660 dollars to
travel to new york city to take on a
group of pro castro students who had
just returned from cuba
spending the summer there and were going
to speak out in defense of what of what
castro was doing the dre leaders went
there uh provoked a brawl in town hall
that turned into a mini riot in the
streets of times square
and uh and
this was clearly what uh
what joe and eddie's intended because he
gave them the money to go do it and
to strengthen one of the reasons why i
believe uh joe and edie's hand is so
deeply involved this on the way back two
of those members of the dre are invited
to give testimony to the house on
american committees activity the house
on american activities committee about
pro-castro activity in the united states
so that's what the dre's purpose was
that's why the cia was funding them
the senate select committee on
intelligence later on they were they
were investigating the fair play for
cuba committee as far back as 1960 they
talked to people like robert tabor and
um bt lee testified in february of 63
and william c kramer the congressman
from
st petersburg florida who was the
biggest foe the fair play for cuba
committee in congress
um testified and
you know talked about a huge uh way to
bring people in this country who were
pro castro that castro was sending his
agents in the united states may have
been true you know i don't know if his
particular trail of uh the fair play for
cuba committee was definitely funded by
the cuban government and this wrangled
people at the cia to no end because
bush was uh you know apparently claimed
that robert tabor received a thousand
dollars or six thousand i don't think
there's any doubt that the fair play for
cuba committee got support from the
cuban government
that kind of propaganda was the dreas
job all over the western hemisphere
correct
correct yeah
i just wanted to elaborate for a second
on the issue of the falsification of the
record on mexico city and ask for
comment um
i know in ray rocca's deposition to the
hsca which became public recently he
asked at one point well where are all
the earlier cables so even people in
washington not just in from mexico city
uh
recognize the discrepancy in the story
and also um john had mentioned
david phillips story in the washington
post in 76 about this missing tape you
know if you read the two transcripts of
the purported oswald tapes
they're fairly innocuous there's a
couple of disturbing things in them like
where oswald is supposed to have said
well the cubans have my address and and
and
also the the name kostikov or version of
it shows up
um but also at the time the day after um
uh phillips relayed the story about this
missing conversation with somewhat more
sinister connotations
um to the house
they flew down to guadalajara mexico and
interviewed the two tarasov translators
and got them both
to provide the same story in much more
detail um
boris taras off a year and a half later
before the hsca in the blakey era
retracted his story although anna did
not
and i think it ties into this notion of
the bombshell coming up from mexico city
on the 22nd and we don't even really
know
exactly what that bombshell was i think
at this point because it that the
likelihood that the tape of the phone
conversation is something which itself
is not even in the record at this point
yeah it's it's both the uh tapes and uh
the story of his cuban contacts down
there all that had had to go away
um i don't want to get into the tapes
right now i just it would take too much
time i've done that many times 90 of you
heard that before and those who haven't
please contact ben wecht and you can get
the whole interview but i will say uh i
i think uh
it's even more uh not even more
pernicious but it's it's a real problem
that if if uh those cables
were altered now the first guy who
really pushed this button and i think
was probably fired partly for that was
richard sprague
was head of the hsca he ran into this
they were investigating this
and of course when they talked to the
people from mexico station they found
that the same thing review boarded all
of them say that they sent they were
this missing conversation we're talking
about uh
um but all of his contacts with the
cuban consulate were reported uh
angleton's replacement at headquarters
uh kolaris wrote a memo in which he said
that the cables in in october contained
information on oswald's cuban contacts
i know that the review board tried to
get their arms around this uh and maybe
tomorrow jeremy gunn that somebody can
ask him if you hear about this issue
by examining the the serials very
closely to try and get a handle on
whether or not they could establish that
some were missing or there'd been some
hanky-panky and they were so
disorganized that they were unable to do
this which is is ridiculous because the
little ladies and tennis shoes were were
meticulous uh
at the ci if you've ever seen that huge
huge file so right at the point you know
at the fulcrum
when oswald's in mexico city and and
these cables are exchanged it's just
disheveled there's cereals missing you
can't tell anything from it
um
so
for me it's it's uh
you know it's it it's
it's something that that really makes me
mad when i think about it now we try and
put the record back together again and
it's gone uh it's just not there the
tapes
uh we know a little bit more about
because we we can interview people who
listen to them uh like
uh slauson who finally came clean
uh with the review board at long last
that yes he had listened to him a rumor
that we'd heard for what 25 years in the
research community based on a
phone conversation with
our good british friend at the pool side
with with coleman
um
but you know the the issue of of
falsifying the the story out of mexico
city
i think is is very important because
what the ci is doing is hiding what it
knew
about oswald's cuban story before the
assassination
and that's the very story uh that was
used to leverage the warren commission
into being
i'm curious if you guys have thought
about why the sas
would be so keenly interested in oswald
at a time when oswald is so keenly
interested in getting into cuba
yeah let me say that you can take this
one too um
i just i'm not going to go expansive on
my answer to that but i want to bring up
one specific thing that the church
committee i think was volume five or six
it's been a long time so i don't
remember which one
um and it's still classified but this uh
the the report that i'm going to refer
to but it's refr the report is referred
to in a footnote
in volume five or six of the church
committee in which it said that the cia
informed the fbi
uh at the time of oswald's visit that
they they uh to mexico city that they
were going to conduct an operation
against the fpcc to embarrass it
and they were going to disseminate um
[Music]
misleading information to embarrass the
fpcc in
other countries
and it's just in a footnote and i've
written on that i've pointed that out in
a couple of places but
the reason i bring that up and answer
your question why would they be
interested
uh
in the in the dre or excuse me why would
the sas be interested because they they
would uh they were interested in
discrediting the fpcc for once that
would be actually a legitimate
operation
and that's the way i can i conceive of
all this happening uh of of whitten
signing off on stuff that he knows isn't
true that there's there are legitimate
counterintelligence operations going on
in the sas
within which
a conspirator could
depress the the virus until 11 22.
okay so
uh the the people that are doing this
inside the sas i don't see them either
uh as as witting conspirators although
there might have been a fireman over
there i just don't know who you might
know better if you've been talking to
sam halpern and those guys and opening
up this this
echelon at the top of the of the sas
including fitzgerald
but i'll just leave it at that did you
want to add anything to that question
yeah
no i i just i thought jeff it might be a
good idea if
you could
inform people about your current efforts
to get information because
[Music]
it bears on a couple of things including
the new problems that have arisen since
the jfk board
went out of existence yeah actually i'd
like to do that um just one additional
note on david phillips i do want to say
uh
i believe that the interest in oswald uh
that is manifested by uh the dre's
contacts with him in august 1963
probably was related to the fair play
for cuba committee john in his book uh
uh sketches a very interesting uh
counterintelligence operations uh that
cia people did against fairplay for cuba
activists uh earlier uh back in 60 or
earlier in 1960 and david phillips was
deeply involved in those so i don't
think i i think that that's a that
that's the explanation for the nature of
the interest um
last december uh i filed the laws uh a
year ago
i filed a foia to the cia requesting all
records on george joe andes
they wrote back and said that they had
disclosed everything to the jfk review
board
which clearly wasn't true so i thought
in december i filed a lawsuit with jim
representing me and uh made another
request for all
joe ande's related material
and
the cia came back and acknowledged uh
finally that they do have george joe
anitti's material
we request then requested that
they provide us with the easily
accessible documents that didn't need to
be referred to other agencies
immediately and uh hold off on
releasing the other material that had to
be cleared with other agencies until
later in the year
the cia opposed that motion and the
judge recently supported their uh their
motion so the way the lawsuit stands now
is the cia has promised to release
george johannine's material in december
of this year
slight correction
they've promised in december to report
on whether or not there's any
information to be released okay
you have to understand how the cia works
okay
special affairs staff
okay we're done any further questions
okay our next panel is not not scheduled
to meet for another 15 minutes so we can
either go ahead or
test take a break we had a short break
earlier
yeah yeah
here's what's ahead on c-span
next a discussion on the garrison
investigation into president